[Musique]
je la comprends d'autant plus que le
parti de gauche auquel j'appartiens a
demandé lors de son dernier conseil
national à jean-luc l'enfant d'être le
candidat de la france ainsi mise pour
2022 donc par ailleurs il avait consulté
l'ensemble des un souvenir vous envoyez
un mail avec un formulaire de france
et puis donc c'est quelque chose qu'on
attendait il ya plusieurs raisons pour
ses 18 mois de campagne la première
raison c'est l'objectif de la france a
soumises clairement n'est pas simplement
de rassembler la gauche ou voilà notre
objectif c'est d'aller convaincre les
abstentionnistes convaincre les
abstentionnistes elle ne peut pas se
faire sur une campagne de six mois ça
prend un temps même 18 mois ces mêmes
sans doute malheureusement trop
force que la france a soumis sa et et
l'originalité de ses campagnes
ça a été bien sûr les hologrammes de 17
mais depuis nous avons fait une caravane
des droits sociaux qui s'est arrêtée
dans les épices genre de démarche
d'éducation populaire également d'aller
aider les gens dans leurs quartiers à
s'investir
eh bien nous allons nous continuer